restaurant anglais poétiquement faible Jones
seulement 40 n vous dis Tony Avella
rêve de désespoir sur la pointe des pieds bob
chapman raviolis yo la vida Brian
darisanam prends ce que tu as fait exactement
avec la fête
je suis surpris que tu m'aies posé cette question
personne je pensais que tu savais mais je  je veux dire je
veux dire j'ai dirigé la vie de brian j'ai
dirigé le sens de la vie et j'ai co-dirigé
la relique sacrée terry gilliam maintenant derry
tu ne penses pas que le succès de
Monty Python est venu de ce qui est visuel chez
Boone Charles oh et ce qui est cérébral  dans
lequel les gens s'éloignent parfois, c'est
juste que je dérive de leurs quatre humeurs et
bien ouais je pense qu'il y a un peu de ça
dedans je pense honnêtement qu'il y a beaucoup de
trucs visuels dans monty python et il y
a beaucoup de trucs cérébraux entre nous John
s'il te plait il est  être intelligent tout le temps
Mike et moi nous avons juste besoin d'être drôles d'
accord que pensez-vous de moi vous étiez
les Beatles après ces John Lennon a
écrit à partir des meilleures chansons qu'ils aient jamais
séparées je veux dire je pense imaginer que c'est l'
année  mon vieux favori je pense à toutes
ces chansons d'accord contrairement aux
services personnels Erik le Viking vient en fait
du livre que vous avez écrit à l'origine pour
votre fils oui j'ai écrit à l'origine
cette série de magasin ça s'appelle le
Sardar très Viking pour ma facture de fils mais
ça  il était environ neuf quatre-vingt-trois maintenant je
pensais bien que cela pourrait faire des films
ou de bonnes images dedans mais après un
moment je me suis un peu ennuyé avec ça je
pensais bien qu'il avait besoin de témoins d'
histoires publiées sous forme de livre je veux dire je ne le fais pas
Je veux aller faire devrait passer deux ans de ma vie à tourner dans un film, alors j'ai en quelque
sorte abandonné l'idée après avoir essayé quelques
scénarios et tout à coup j'ai trouvé
cette équipe de viol qui est maintenant la première
scène du film et j'ai pensé que je  Je ne l'ai pas fait
si quelque chose d'autre et reniflé l'a trouvé dans
un tiroir et j'ai pensé que c'était une
scène assez drôle et peut-être qu'il y avait une
histoire là-bas, alors j'ai soudainement voté pour certains,
c'était totalement différent, donc même si ça
s'appelle Erik le Viking ce n'est pas le même que
le  le livre pour enfants du tout, je veux dire
qu'il n'y a pas de vaccin dans le livre de jordans et je
viens d'utiliser quelques exemples le
dragon de la mer du Nord et aller
au bout du monde bien les
services personnels bien sûr je n'ai pas voté pour le
projet de loi sur lequel
il est basé  l'histoire vraie l'histoire du
sous-sol à propos de Cynthia Pain qui est
une vraie dame à Londres qui dirigeait ce
bordel et une banlieue très respectable du sud de
Londres, personne ne le savait jusqu'à ce que
la police fasse une descente en un jour, alors les
Vikings sont presque en train de devenir
prévenu sur la bonne voie à nouveau non Terry
imagine que je suis un riche
producteur hollywoodien célèbre comment obtiendrez-vous 12
millions de dollars hmm oh uh une fois étrange que
vous essayez de vous mettre au lit vous
savez aussi mais cela ne fonctionne généralement pas
la plupart du temps  eux alors la prochaine chose que je
viens vers vous avec cette merveilleuse idée de
tirer le Viking J'ai Alan Lee pour
dessiner toutes ces images, il est de belles
images parce qu'étant un
producteur hollywoodien, je sais que vous ne savez pas lire alors je
vous montre ces images  et je vous raconte cette
histoire et ensuite articule la complicité même
pas beaucoup Charles et si j'étais un
mouvement très paresseux il y a comment vendre c'est
bien filmer si nous étions vraiment paresseux euh je me suis
beaucoup amusé à vous vendre quatre autres trois démissionner
non Terry est  il est vrai que vous avez donné un rôle
à John Cleese afin d'obtenir de l'argent
de la Scandinavie hmm en fait je ne
voulais pas du tout donner des dents au bar Jon
ce qui s'est passé, c'est que John a proposé d'être dans
le film si nous étions vraiment sûrs de pouvoir
Je n'ai pas collecté d'argent et j'ai dit non
non, je ne veux
aucune référence aux Monty Python, puis environ un
mois plus tard, j'ai préparé dans l'un de nos horribles
journaux anglais une interview de
John Cleese dans laquelle il a dit qu'il
allait jouer  un rôle dans mon film donc j'ai dû le
lui offrir après ça ou le